hemos hablado bastante acerca de como el
gobierno chino está imprimiendo ioannes
para comprar moneda extranjera y
mantener el yuan devaluado ok entonces
lo que lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo
es mirar los datos para mostrar que no
estaba inventando todo eso ok estos son
datos actuales del banco popular de
china esto es directo desde su sitio web
ok y justo aquí esta reserva de dinero
desde 2010 y esta es la reserva de 2009
aunque puedes obtener la reserva de
dinero de cualquier año que desees desde
su portal web lo que podemos hacer es
mirar lo que pasó en el 2010 desde el
mismo punto en 2009 y 2010 ok ok
entonces déjenme tomar de noviembre de
2009 a noviembre de 2010
ok voy a fijarme en su reserva de m1
vamos de noviembre a noviembre porque
veremos de algunas otras de las gráficas
que va a mostrar que no tenemos de
diciembre a diciembre para algunas otras
y que vamos a usar en este vídeo esto
solo nos da la idea general si vamos de
noviembre de 2009 la reserva m 1 esto
esto está en cientos de millones de
yuans ok había 212 mil 493 cientos de
millones de jones vamos a intentar
convertir esto en números que hagan un
poco más de sentido vámonos rápido de
noviembre de 2010 el m1 es 259 mil 420
cientos de millones de yuans saquemos la
calculadora para hacer que esto tome un
poco de sentido así que un año después
dijimos
259 mil 420 de eso vamos a restar lo que
había antes que eran 212 mil
ok así que la diferencia es 46 mil 927
esto les recuerda estén cientos de
millones de yuans si lo quieres en
millones de ayudan lo que tendríamos que
hacer es multiplicar por 100 pero que
esto se pronuncia como johann o one no
soy un experto en pronunciación china
pero bueno esto nos da 4 esto es en
millones de jong verdad si lo que
quieres es en miles de millones podemos
dividir en esto por 1000 vamos a dividir
esto por 1000 así que gruesamente son 4
mil 692 miles de millones de yuans que
incrementaron en su reserva m 1 de
noviembre de 2009 a noviembre de 2010
ok un dramático aumento podemos poner
esto en términos de dólares usar una
aproximación para la tasa de cambio
digamos de 6.5 yuan por dólar así que
déjenme dividir eso por 6.5 para obtener
una aproximación de lo que debería ser
en dólares y ahí está tenemos 722
1722 miles de millones de dólares de
expansión en la reserva en uno de china
de noviembre de 2009 a noviembre de 2010
ok ahora en el próximo vídeo veremos
como esto se compara con su actual
incremento en cambio extranjero de hecho
en activos en el extranjero
y podemos ver como mucho de esto iría a
comprar cosas de otros países o comprar
monedas de otras naciones y
esencialmente mantener devaluado al yuan
chino estamos desde lacan academy para
la cnc